i guess we should start with dubai watch
week i just watched your
panel discussion and i think a lot of
people would be surprised to see
high tech being matched with watchmaking
do you think people are surprised by
that well i think it's high time coming
because there's two huge problems in the
watch industry and the watch after
market and for watch collectors as well
first of all watch prices have
appreciated remarkably in the last two
years we've never seen anything like
this in the 200 year 300 year history of
watchmaking
and so think about it pragmatically no
one needs a mechanical watch everybody
gets perfect time off their cell phone
and yet now watchers are being treated
like collectible art
and so the biggest problem that emerges
when you start getting multi-million
dollar price points for watches is
fraud
fake watches never have they been so
well made and so
we need technology to authenticate the
real watch from the real brand from the
real maker so that when people are
paying 200 300 400 500 000 and more they
know they're getting something
that's validated and real
so one of the things you said in that
discussion that i didn't quite
understand i understand
taking the crypto um
technology and attaching it to an object
so it can be traced and traded and all
of that but you were acting like you
could actually take
they were two separate items that the
crypto version the etf version could be
sold separately from the actual watch
did i understand that right yes here's
how it would work
first of all number one reason
anytime any of this happens it's because
there's an economic reason to do it so
you think about changing an industry
standards the only reason you could get
adoption would be that there's a really
strong economic reason to do it and in
the case of watch nfts there is and
there are and let's just start with the
idea when a watch is born when it's made
when it leaves the maker's hands the
creator's hands
they take a digital image of it a very
very high resolution digital image that
captures every aspect of the watch
itself its dial its movement its caliber
the sound it makes if it's a repeater
the sound it makes when the movement is
wound all of that information at the
bench of the creator now that's going to
live with that watch in perpetuity and
that's serial number zero zero zero nft
it becomes the authentication nft it
remains the digital image of that watch
forever however
that doesn't mean there isn't more
economic value to be had let's say we
agreed the standard was that there'd be
three additional nfts that were also
issued by the creator at the moment the
watch was put to market and those are
tradable nfts so you as the owner of the
watch you buy the watch
now you have a decision do you keep all
your nfts together or do you sell off
some of them perhaps to pay for
insurance or perhaps because you want to
trade them particularly in high-end
pieces where maybe there's only one of a
kind the kind of watches i collect i've
had countless people call me up and say
can i buy an nft of that particular
piece i know you own because it's the
only one in the world
and i've been very interested to do that
because i want to support our the art of
watchmaking and the idea would be with
these trade in the market the original
creator of the watch would get a royalty
and i as the original owner would also
get a royalty or you could build a smart
contract any way you want
as the value of that watch increases
over time the value of those nfts that
are trading the open market would also
increase
and that i estimate and look it's a
personal estimation but i don't think
i'm wrong and it certainly captured the
attention of the watch industry into at
watch week in dubai
if we did that overnight to all the
watches in existence today i think the
market capitalization of the watch
industry would increase by 30 overnight
due to the value of the digital nfts
that is a very large number and exactly
why this is going to happen
why would someone want a digital nft
that's not connected to a watch that's
just the nft well there's many reasons
there's many use cases people like
artists work
there's a woman selling her eggs as an
nft right now so if you can't have
children you can buy the nft and she
will deliver the eggs i mean that may
sound crazy but that's exactly what she
did because she's using a smart smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain
what is happening here has many use
cases i mean going back to the watch
industry the old way of authentication
was you got papers with your watch and
then you had to find an expert to make
sure that when they looked at it it
wasn't a forgery it wasn't a fake that's
very expensive very time consuming with
a digital
nft that basically has a really high
resolution image of the watch it's much
harder to fake it and i think the
industry needs something like this and
we'll eventually adopt it i'm just being
part of and funding some of the research
it's going to take to get this work done
because i'm a very large watch collector
we haven't even talked about the
insurance aspect of this let me give you
an example
i have extremely large numbers of
watches in bank vaults all around the
world under the streets of zurich under
the streets of geneva under the streets
of new york
i don't need to insure those they're
under a bank
i need to ensure the 10 or 12 or 15 that
i'm traveling with and they're always
changing all the time as i arrive in one
city and pulls them out of the vault if
i had an nft i could let the insurance
company know these are the watches that
i have with me now here is the city i'm
in they can see this right on the smart
chain and they can basically reduce my
insurance costs by up to 80 percent
and i'm very interested in having that
happen and they would expand the number
of insurance contracts they would have
because everybody that an nft could just
click a button on their app and get bid
insurance when they take a trip or they
want their watch insured there's just so
many use cases for this technology i am
sure with 100 certainty all of this is
going to happen
your white paper what are you suggesting
or do you know yet what you're going to
suggest the why
the white paper is designed to actually
have input from all the participants all
the stakeholders
watch collectors number one watch makers
number two
watch insurance companies number three i
mean we need all of them on board for
the standards and a fourth participant
that's very interested are all the watch
resellers and retailers out there that
sell the brand new watches and also sell
in the secondary market the secondary
market for watches is
is massive compared to the primary
market i mean there's only so many
watches made a year but there's billions
of dollars worth of watches being traded
every year from the ones that were
vintage to the new ones that were just
bought last year so there's many many
different participants and the white
paper is designed to get the input and
get a standard established it's the same
idea of ip protocol on the internet
decades ago you need a standard by which
this works and i'm one of the people
championing that i'm sure there's others
and happy to work with them but i want
to get this done in my lifetime because
i have a very large watch collection and
i want to put nfts on all of them
it's quite well known that you had your
watch collection stolen twice
would this help with
well that's never going to happen again
because the watch collection is never in
one place anymore and yes i have gone
through the misery of two collections
being stolen both we believe inside jobs
that first of all it's impossible now
number two is this would really [ __ ]
the ability to resell the watch the
minute you have a watch stolen again
using the smart contract on the on the
blockchain you notify the police you can
notify interpol saying this watch has
been stolen it's no longer in my
possession and now when the thief tries
to resell it to any accredited collector
or eventually try to service it doesn't
matter how many times it gets traded
it's going to eventually get caught
because the nft is now flagged as a
stolen piece
where does watch collection
fit into your life you're an
entrepreneur you finance companies you
play guitar
where does it fit in here
watch collecting is a horrible disease
it's a virus once you're cursed with it
your life is miserable the only reason
you work is to buy more watches and
that's exactly where i'm at right now
i mean
you i can't even repeat what my wife
says to me when i bring home another
watch
i i i couldn't possibly if i wore ten a
day i would never i'd never have time to
wear them all and so
i really look at it as an asset class i
really look at it as supporting artists
who dedicate their lives from the age of
14 to make these incredible pieces i
enjoy the lifestyle of talking to the
ceos of these watch companies and the
designers the camaraderie of other
collectors as we share our different
stories
the jordan society for example the fp
journal society
not that it's easy to get into it
anymore but just look what's happened to
that brand in the last 10 years just
last five years
my watches have appreciated 400 500 600
from when i bought them just a few years
ago and so you know i enjoy the the
whole idea it's very much akin to what i
do in the wine industry i love the wine
industry because i deal with winemakers
all around the world same in the watch
industry
i like to watch us not
hear a little
but
i got to tell you there's a camaraderie
there when you uh are just at a party
someone spots a watch and you start a
conversation does that happen to you oh
absolutely the whole idea and this is
the premise of collecting watches
i collect dials that start conversations
i can't tell you how many times i've
been stopped traveling in business or
just on the street and some person says
to me what is that on your wrist
maybe it's you know some remarkable dial
that pejor made or maybe a patek or
whatever and how do you tell the time
with that and i said i don't use this to
tell the time i am wearing art this is a
piece of art and i'm celebrating the
artist who made this dial so i'm all
about the dial at this point
in my collecting site lifetime i guess
i don't buy production watches anymore i
work with watch companies that are
willing to make me one-of-a-kind pieces
i don't ask for anything for free but
i'm interested in working with them to
create a one-of-a-kind mr wonderful
watch something that no one else has
ever seen before a dial that you can't
even imagine
something remarkable in its style
and and celebrate that brand with that
one-of-a-kind piece now there's where
i'm getting you know
many people asking for the nfts of those
but
every year because usually it takes two
years to do something like this every
year i get another one of a kind
delivered to me and i celebrate it with
the world i show it to everybody and i'm
proud to wear it and you know
it's it's just the there's nothing more
fun
than having a zoom call with with the
creator and saying no let's move the
dial this way let's change the contrast
of the of the hour hand let's let's you
know let's put this thing full of red
rubies because everybody knows i wear a
red band on all my watches and so i'm
i'm working with them and i'm very proud
to say i've finally reached the status
where i get to do that took a long long
long time but now that i can do it i do
it for everybody that appreciates
watches seeing a one-of-a-kind watch is
a remarkable experience i've seen grown
men weep in front of one of a kind
weep
weep
weep the tears of joy and envy at the
same time
how do you tell a young guy or not a
young guy how do you tell anybody who
wants to collect they've been thinking
about it they've watched you on shark
tank they see the red band um i i
believe you're the one who made the
panda you know real well known uh what
do you tell somebody if they want to
start
yeah that panda sold at auction a couple
of years ago for a crazy price to
support a great charity one drop i'm
proud you know i have to admit it really
broke my heart to let it go i didn't
realize how emotionally attached i was
with to it that was the red banded uh
white steel face daytona panda with the
black ceramic
um
i had worn that in every season of shark
tank for 13 years in a row that's that's
a one of a kind watch in itself but
anyways i'm glad it went to a great
owner and
you know many many people have asked for
the nft of that and i just will not do
it
until we've got the standard in the
white paper and i wouldn't do that
because rolex shouldn't do that until
there's a standard but anyways um i i
tell young collectors
when you start
go for value i mean
you know you can't this is a horrible
disease and it's going to take up a lot
of your time and money and so you have
to be pragmatic start with a brand that
gives you incredible value something
like a grand seiko
where you can get a movement akin to a
patek philippe in quality at a much more
affordable price beautiful dials
incredible pieces grand seikos are
probably a great place to start the
entry-level pieces from rolex and from
patek now have skyrocketed i mean
watches that used to cost 12 000
trade in the secondary market for 55 000
and that's not an easy piece first for
someone who's in their 20s i you know
the number one piece that young
engineers want when they graduate is the
is the daytona the white-faced steel
daytona and and that's just in the
secondary market it costs more than your
education to buy it so it's you know
it's it's gone crazy you have to look
for value and there's many other brands
i support them all i i and you know i
work with all kinds of
videographers and bloggers teddy balazar
does a great job i always say teddy
your video should when you and i do them
together let's explore value for people
coming into the market in their 20s and
he's done a great job doing that yeah
i've seen some of those you guys do a
great job uh president biden is he a
good collector of watches does he know
what he's doing
you know there's lots of rumors about
him but i'll tell you the other uh well
i'm not sure he's a president he's more
like a dictator but putin
um has made the canola metro blue the
blue dialed fp journey a legendary piece
he wore it
people saw it on his wrist and that that
particular brand went from a seventeen
thousand dollar value to a hundred and
ten thousand so a a world leader like
abide near a putin can change the
destiny of a brand with just one citing
it on their wrist it's remarkable
have you ever designed a watch start to
finish or do you always work with a
designer
i always work with a brand that no who
knows who i am that i've already
collected and what i do is there may be
a certain design that i fall in love
with and i want to take off the piece
does i like to say you know move it a
little bit over in terms of what's going
to it's always the dial design i want to
work with and and
i'm very fortunate these makers because
changing a dial is incredibly time
consuming a one of a kind has to be
painted and fired it's not easy to do
there are some great one-of-a-kinds
coming i have two of them coming from
you know
i am not disclosing yet who they are but
i was working with teddy again we were
talking about him and he showed me a new
designer a new up-and-coming rock star
and and i loved the dial and i called
him up and said look would you make me a
one of a kind mr wonderful on this style
and they've agreed to do it and i'll be
featuring that on season 14 of shark
tank it is a stunning piece but i don't
want to give it all away now it's going
to be
it's going to get a lot of coverage on
on the watch bloggers for sure
why are watches so popular now
and why are the prices going through the
roof
well you've actually that's a great
question and an answer at the same time
because the the the price appreciation
and i'll tell you what i think has
happened there's a strong correlation
between
people that are into cryptocurrencies
and watch collecting for example a brand
called richard min is very popular with
bitcoin enthusiasts those squatches are
a quarter of a million dollars and you
see them on the wrist you go to a
conference like miami last year bitcoin
2021 you saw plenty of fp journals
plenty of of richard mills plenty of
rolexes plenty of pateks lots and lots
of them and so people that are into
crypto have all of a sudden got that
watch bug and they're realizing it
doesn't matter how much money you have
it's access to the watch so again going
back to the example of fp journal
you
fp jordan himself has to understand why
you're buying his watch before he'll
sell it to you he only makes 900 watches
a year you have to be a collector you
have to honor the art and support the
brand and and share the vision of the
other collectors eighty-seven percent of
the inventory is held by the fp journal
society these are hardcore collectors so
he has he is he's sort of the picasso
the living picasso of watchmaking and
while he's alive if you can get one of
his pieces you know with certainty
there's only one direction the price of
that watch is going and i mean i don't
want this to happen but post fp journey
those watches are going to be priceless
would you suggest investing in watches
let's say you didn't even like them you
don't care about
decent value
are they worth it on that level alone
they are but i think that's a sin i
think if you don't wear a watch you keep
it in a box you're destroying its soul i
really believe that and listen we i have
huge debates online with watch
collectors that that buy pieces and
never take them out of the box i think
that's just an absolute sin they should
burn in hell in perpetuity for that a
watch is is designed to be put on your
wrist and shown to other enthusiasts and
other supporters of the art yes it's
going to get scratched but that's part
of the patina i have to remind everybody
that's listening paul newman's watch
which was scuffed and never polished
sold for 17.5 million dollars the
original paul newman daytona in auction
because it it was part of him it was
part of his life it was seen with him
all the time on his wrist that's how a
watch should be honored
is there one watch you don't have you
wish you had
well there's always one there's no
question about that there's always one
but you know i i must say that i thought
i had a really huge collection perhaps
one of the largest on earth until i got
to the united arab emirates and met some
of the royal family there i was humbled
they are the largest watch collectors in
the world and they're very very discreet
about it i was honored to see some of
the most incredible collections i have
ever seen
i mean it was
it just took my breath away if you're
into watches you've never seen like this
and
i'm glad it happened to me because it
humbled me but it also inspired me and
so i'm going to try and catch up with
those guys
i'll ask one final question what did i
not ask you about watches that i should
have
you know at the end of the day
you know what what drives people into
this madness
it's a passion
and
unfortunately
it starts at around your fifth watch i
always say the point of no return is the
purchase of the sixth timepiece
it's over and so
curb your enthusiasm into the extent if
you don't want to get stuck in this
horrible place
where you spend all this time and money
pursuing these remarkable timepieces
don't collect more than six stop at five
stop at five if you like that video wait
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe